the thing that I find particularly
interested in it comes we talk about the
hierarchies of privilege the the number
one the apex for a hierarchy of
privilege seems to be old white men
which to me seems incredibly ages
because a lot of old people in this
country quite frankly are struggling
economically financially you know barely
able to get through the month yeah you
know like we were saying earlier about
sort of facts and reality isn't really
what this all about
and you know it's ideological and I
think devote an interesting aspect with
older people is that they appear as
being regressive and backward and and
for example I mean you could say there
is some reason for for saying that you
know for example that racist may be
sexist attitudes and in a certain sense
are more common amongst you know older
people of previous generations but I
doubt that's more of an excuse I think
to sort of bash them but I think it's
this is where progressive you know the
progressive elements of politics comes
in because progressive politics is
really about it's about things improving
over time getting better over time and
it's a faith that that's happening so in
that sense people who are around you
know in previous times are naturally
sort of worse and more regressive than
you know young people is that for
example so if you find sort of
progressive politicians they tend to
exalt the younger and then dismiss the
older which I mean I agree with you I
think that's a really bad way of you
know addressing especially from the left
solidarity in society you know of
dismissing people who have been on this
earth for a lot longer than we have have
a lot more experience and just
dismissing of them as if they have
nothing valuable to offer I think that's
that's a terrible approach any one I
think there should be like a cutoff
point for like white privilege once you
get to like a seventy you've got some
kind of waste disease
so where your privileges and you just
hold off super oh [ __ ] yeah exactly
thank you for taking that joke into a
very very dark place because when people
criticize Trump a number of times when
what I sought from people is I what do
you expect he's an old white man it was
just like of all the things I don't
agree with Trump in the moment what he
said vote my mom's Venezuela Venezuelan
can't go into America but it just seems
such a bizarre thing to accuse somebody
of you know it's saying that he's older
is a old white male therefore he has
these views it comes by two it's just so
easy isn't it yeah and you know this
again what I'm talking about with social
system a diversity it's like you can say
that so if you said that on Twitter you
know you see people saying that on
Twitter they'll get thousands of
retweets you just make these kinda lazy
remarks and you know I guess you're it's
an effective form of politics you know
it's so easy we can all grab hold of it
and there you go guys if you want to be
a social media influence oh you know
what to do yeah you know where to take
it
you got fat shame to hell as well Trump
dude it's perfectly respectable to fat
shame Donald Trump but don't years got
fat ass to be honest how do you know oh
yeah I've seen pictures of it nice to
know what kind of porn you watch anyway
you talk about a couple of things which
I think are really important and let's
get to both of them before we ask our
very final question first of all you
talked about the false power of
prediction people talking about how this
is what's gonna happen and then this is
what's gonna happen if we don't do that
then this is gonna happen and eventually
none of it happens and we all keep going
as if if this those predictions
been made you know and that person
didn't lose any credibility we just keep
predicting stuff that never happens hmm
and then just carry on as if everything
is the same so talk to us about that bit
well I think it's a it comes down to you
know the authority that appears from
knowledge and you know obviously there's
a there's a good reason for that
you know but obviously it depends on if
the knowledge is actually real or not
now the thing with predictions is you
know by definition the truth is not
verified you know you can't tell what's
going to happen before it but
predictions appear as if they are
truthful you know especially if they
come from someone you know who is
authoritative you know who works for so
the Bank of England you know a big
organization big international
organization you know anyone who
produces reports so basically anyone
who's you know sort of organized and
they they can produce something which
appears our ferocity and you can make
predictions and and that appears as a
form of knowledge but it's obviously
it's it's obviously sort of well well
you you know like I said before you
can't verify either way so that
predictions kind of appear in the public
sphere as authoritative and there's no
way to to demonstrate that until
whatever they predict it either happens
or doesn't and of course by the time
that happens the whole the whole circus
has moved on so you can even predict
another thing and with the same level of
authority yeah as long as you have the
position and the ability to you know
contact the media and they you know the
authoritative 'ti from the media to get
your stuff out there you can keep on you
know replaying and it doesn't really
matter I mean some people are obviously
going to pick you up on it but most
people out there and not really paying
attention do you realize what you've
just done is given a blueprint to how to
become a guardian Journal cold people
yeah and then that's it
I mean it's interesting that you know
because it does seem to be that you can
make these you know these grandiose
predictions and everybody discusses it
and then next week we've gone to
something else and really isn't the only
point of a prediction so that you can
end up with four words told I told you
so I mean that's essentially it isn't it
and then people go back to it and then
go look I was wrong I mean that that
would be the you know the you know
approach which follows you know the the
disciplines of theory and knowledge and
checking and falsifying and and and then
you know looking to revise if theories
and all the rest of it but politics
isn't like that you know it's it's it's
more about authority and getting your
thing out there yeah it's it's not I
told you so it's it's about what you're
telling people is going to happen yeah
and then that allows you to control what
happens in the present right
yes it's about shaping the message today
so the different decisions get made
because you've predicted something yeah
yeah exactly another final point I want
to ask you about as well is you talked
about you know one of my one of the
we're very big fans of Dave Rubin and
his show and he talks a lot about the
power of good ideas over bad ideas which
is something that I you know I share as
well I think ideas are very important
discussing them is very important which
is one of the reasons we do the show but
one of the things you mentioned in the
book and you make quite quite clear is
that this ideology that we're talking
about the ideology of social justice of
diversity and whatever you will not be
defeated through ideas because they're
not fighting that cultural war through
ideas they're fighting it through
institutions which they've seized
control over right so what is the answer
man we've got about 30 seconds to come
up with a blueprint for how we solve
this crisis of Western civilization go
well I don't think there isn't a silver
bullet and I was joking I know there's
no sort of well I I think it's it's it's
basically about all of us who are
concerned and give a [ __ ] that we we do
get active and we organize and we
contact each other
and we form institutions and to do that
you need money and you need people
prefer 2 billion hard work and you know
this this takes time means like I say
with with the book you know sort of
exploring this idea of a system of
diversity no I didn't use that word by
mistake it's you know it's systemic in a
sense but you can you can't break out of
it but you're taking a risk when you do
everyone is taking a risk and to make to
make any sort of politics which is we're
drawing away from that or criticizing
that well preserving are the elements
which are good hopefully has got a you
know be organized and rigorous and well
financed so I mean this this isn't easy
we don't do it just by sitting and
pontificating like we do here yeah like
I'm doing yeah like weird
[Music]